welcome to this video against Ted rock
Tetrarch we check this an old name okay
I'm going for a g6 set up we get them do
we get modern defense on something like
that yeah probably Pickens defense he's
probably playing the c3 year or
everything indicates that he's going to
do that yep and okay if I've is the way
to go yeah how do you play that here
with black I'm just going to try to
place some quick moves rook e8 h 6 kind
of normal-looking moves that fit into
the pollution well that's actually quite
a good setup for white I have from
played this myself once in a while it's
a very yeah it's a very sound way to
play and yeah asking black a little bit
what what his counter players White has
the center and it's not so clear what
Blake does
is coming with be five that's not it's
looking very nice actually maybe come on
b5 I have to go back to be 80 know is
doing this yeah there is some logic and
the night hornby 8 is not really great
yeah this looks like a very nice version
of the Kings Indiana where my
centralized pieces look a look very very
questionable okay that is a bad opening
result how do I get some kind of player
can I are preparing f5 it's not that
easy even and probably I should put this
here and then the Knight to d7
to get it over to the King side I mean
the only thing that wow it's helping me
a little bit is that the night on c2 is
not so great at the moment for him I
probably will get it to see fire night
III to see for this kind of thing yeah
yeah I know it's a it's not very nice
maybe better here to be six okay so I
have to get something going here if he
takes at least my bishop is playing so I
expect his his Bishop to move yeah yeah
yeah this is also ok yeah it's nothing i
can do have to have to give a 7 up so
the only very very limited hope that i
have is some kind of Hail Mary
counter-attack which is not really
looking very likely to succeed to be
perfectly honest
yeah I completely miss played that yeah
this this opening looks terrible
absolutely terrible so what can I do
here is there some kind of trickery that
I can employ okay he's almost promoting
here but if I check him lamka Queen
takes 93 he was probably relaxing a
little bit too early but he has 95 year
that's its lucky for wider I mean I
don't think he saw that him beforehand
but it is of course is of course good
fam
should have taken t3
yeah I'm a look under look up in this
position but look at this night look at
this point I have absolutely nothing
here that I can do to stop it min b7 em
we can even go b7 yeah or that one it's
really it's remarkably bad takes 8 p-7
and oh and that's it
yeah okay b7 I can take a five and sort
of continued now I did still probably
completely winning but it feels like he
should have had something even better
okay still be seven as hitting there's
some some kind of play some kind of
thing I can do against b7 rookie 70 and
b7 taking it probably
somehow it hits its not falling apart
very easily he has a win somewhere but
it's not completely apparent what it is
would be one I take you for all of a
sudden okay wants to take here
and b7 is also in the mix and okay now
you can take my be 70 actually having a
move he's also trading be eight this is
this is a big problem time morning p 8
any kind of tricky
some somehow
not really am yeah come on laughs yeah I
was funny that was a funny funny way to
play yeah okay I played the opening I
mean I really have no idea about this is
in detail but it was really a bad bad
opening result so here why it is just
much much better but what he did is I
think he he still screwed it up a little
bit this I cannot really believe in but
maybe it's maybe it is working yeah that
it still wins I mean I don't think if
you're shirtless here he took a couple
of seconds here I don't think he really
saw this either thought the bonds are
pushing through it it's not mattering
him it's just completely winning just
completely winning and I had no
alternative I was afterwards I was
briefly thinking okay maybe I could have
taken here but this is this is really
not mattering a lot that I can take you
out because i have no attack and look at
this yeah the bonsai just just
completely running me over yeah here
it's as funny yeah why does a rook down
but it's it's not mattering at all it's
really not mattering them and that
everything winds be seven wins and and
everything this is good young Adam it is
it is totally enough you simply have no
chance against those three points I was
kind of hanging on for a while but this
is just over wow yeah okay it said that
happens if you really play play a really
bad opening him it was really hard to
come back yeah I didn't really didn't
really think about it that much that he
can always play d5 and this is of course
all nice and good but if you place d5
this is totally misplaced so I was
really badly played this this
yeah I don't I don't exactly know how
black and is playing this this kind of
position of course to be perfectly
honest I would always want to have YTM
given white central control but it is
it's not supposed to be that bad maybe
here yeah this this kind of thing this
looks a bit better I mean queen is Sam
look da that's really nonsense it's just
putting pieces on totally the wrong
squares okay well thanks for watching